first of all this is so compelling
it's so connecting um
the whole time i felt like i was in the
room with you guys
and of course i have a million questions
for you but first i just wanted to ask
because i think the biggest
takeaway for people is going to be wow
she shares so much
demi lovato is no holds barred in this
was there anything off limits for you
guys
really wasn't um i think she
surprised herself with just how much she
was sharing
i don't even know why i'm sober anymore
out of control hey be careful
okay i felt like i needed to tell you
that i'm always here
jimmy's good at making you believe that
she's okay demi is very
good at hiding what she needs to hide i
crossed a line
that i had never crossed i think though
as the
project continued to evolve and as she
continued to grow and do the self work
she was even surprised at just how much
she ended up wanting to share
um which is all about the safe space
and the ability you know to ultimately
get our story out there and i was just
there to listen
and document it what is that driving
force that made demi
want to open up so much i think it's the
ultimate catharsis you know i think
these documentary premium documentary
big splashy events
the reason they're so popular is it's a
it's an opportunity to really speak your
truth
when there's so much false headlines and
misinformation out there in the world
here's a platform an opportunity to
directly state um what's going on
and and i think demi now you know she's
she's worked on documentaries in the
past
and she talked about how sometimes when
she looks back at those projects she was
trying to be honest she just wasn't
ready yet i think she really was ready
here and i think it shines through
demi and i had a very uh upfront
conversation about our goals with this
project
and once those goals aligned that she
really wanted to tell the truth
about everything that was her goal her
objective was to
clear the air to tell her story to speak
her truth so
i think that the opportunity to really
take a year
and spend time allowing somebody into
your world
getting that trust and then ultimately
releasing a product
into the world is not so much about
meticulously editing a false narrative
quite the opposite it's about taking the
time to
do the self work think through
ultimately what your goal is
and then release a cohesive piece that
you could share with the audience
and you can jump on live and say
whatever you're feeling that day but
that's impulsive and
in the moment whereas this is you know
you're going to get to know demi lovato
through and through in this piece at the
end of the day how involved was demi
with saying yes this can go in or no
this can't with that final editing
process
there's nothing that she cut from the
film i remember the first time i showed
her
the first time we sat in her theater and
i pressed play and about eight seconds
in she asked me if
it was one of those ipads she said can
you stop it for a second
and um i could see she was you know
vis she was physically reacting to and
all we got through was the scene in rock
and rio in 2018
and she had a like physical reaction
where it just overwhelmed her because
she hadn't really looked at footage from
that time in her life and it brought
back so many memories
and i'm sitting there going ooh if if if
that's all she's
she's seen so far and she's reacting to
what we're in for
um quite an intense viewing but she um
leaned into it and anything that she
made her uncomfortable she understood
the power
of that and you know most importantly
demi's not telling anybody how to live
their life
everybody's got their own unique
situations she's simply telling you what
she's been through her unique journey
and um you know i think that will
provide an opportunity for others to do
the same
just like you had to stop when you were
watching were there any moments that
come to mind where you had to stop
filming where she needed a minute or
moments that come to mind to you as
the most powerful intense interviews you
did with her
i think one of our later interviews you
know there's always this battle because
you become very close with whoever
you're working with
so when something um so genuine is
taking place you need to roll as much as
your instincts are
you have to fight those urges to sort of
stop um because
that's ultimately what the person wants
and that's you're there to
see that through i think some of the
conversations about prior trauma um
in her the earlier years for life uh
were really heavy
i wasn't sure when or if we were going
to talk about those in the detail we did
and i remember
um that happening and feeling um it was
just a really intense moment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so growing close with her spending all
this time and
seeing how much she was still on a
journey while you were filming
did you worry about her during filming
did you
lay in bed at night wondering if you
were gonna get a call because it seems
everybody around her
who cared was at some point still very
worried
so yeah there was some times where just
heavy subject matter would stick with
you and you would think about it and
keep you up and
you know of course you worry a bit um
but
i really believe that uh today demi is
is working on herself
so much and really has gotten to the
root a lot of those things that she's in
the best place she's been
but again she is she's not fixed we
always talked about how this style
it's very hard to wrap up a documentary
and say that's the
on a 28 year old she's 28 years old so
this is uh
the end of a chapter and uh i'm really
proud of where she is and the work she's
doing
i had three strokes i had a heart attack
my doctors said that i had five to ten
more minutes
and she she gets into you know how bad
that night of the overdose really was
how scary it was
i think people will learn for the first
time how truly life or death that
situation was
um how tough was that for her to relive
for her family to relive
what were those interviews like
tough i mean you know sitting down with
her stepfather and mother
and talking about the situation where
they really believe that they may lose
their daughter is difficult
and or even
sitting down with her sisters um her
friends i mean all of the interviews
were really heavy
um this film you know dancing with the
devil ultimately is about a moment in
time
obviously that horrible incident where
the overdose occurred
and ultimately how we got there you know
it's ultimately this like nucleus and
you peel back the
layers of the onion in it and it all
leads you uh in a non-linear way to this
moment and every interview touched on
where you were what happened what went
through your head you know
during that incident and as such all of
them were really difficult
is she alive people are gasping her
oxygen levels are dangerously low i said
what do you mean she's gonna make it
you're watching
all of her blood come out of her body
into a machine
she was like i can't i can't see i can't
see anything
i would say for sure the the
conversation with her parents
was just as much prep work as i did was
really
tough because you could just see the
pain as they sort of relived it
and i think a lot of the people that i
sat down with
hadn't properly spoken about it in the
open to this level
at any point you know because when
you're in it everybody just wants demi
to get better
just get better and then ultimately is
time it's not something you just chat
about every day
i'm engaged i've really struggled with
this
so much continued to change while you
were filming she got engaged she became
unengaged
again in theme with everything else like
to ignore that she fell in love she did
i mean that was she she fell fast you
know quarantine was such a bizarre time
for people
uh loneliness um you know uh was
prevalent
and to leave out max entirely felt like
it would have been
you know inauthentic so i felt it was
important to have demi do some of those
self-taped
confessionals saying hey i know your
goal here is to be authentic
i think you should take five minutes and
direct
you know do a visual diary of how you're
feeling
and that was super powerful when she
sent me um
she sent me the first video which was
her kind of putting on uh
her best game face talking about how she
was
pushing through and then later that
night when she was still up and couldn't
sleep she sent one
where she was really you know letting
the tears out and that's again another
example of
she really was going there she wasn't
afraid to show
her emotions wear her heart on her
sleeve and um
talk about everything going on demi does
say he fooled her and her
friends say he fooled her that happens a
lot i was wondering
is there an explanation there like did
she not want to explain how because you
are sitting and watching and saying well
how did he fool her
my takeaway there and we spoke about at
length was
you know quarantine made people move
fast and i think
you know it takes time to really get to
know somebody and i think they both
moved too fast and
then they ultimately got to know one
another and i think
had it not been quarantined maybe they
wouldn't have been living in the same
place so quickly and all those things
so i think as they both started going
back to work and whatnot um
you know ultimately the relationship
wasn't right uh for both of them
we see uh some cameos first from some
big names christine aguilera pops up and
elton john and will ferrell
how much did that mean to to demi and
what did you think of these
huge people coming in to sit down and
speak on her well i thought it just
it was another key perspective i mean
she's influenced other icons
you know uh she has this incredible
um relationship um like sister
relationship with
christina who's gone through um some
similar stuff
and ultimately i think has been a really
great sound board for her
um and has been a real mentor at times
elton john another one who's had similar
struggles in his life in different ways
and
ultimately provided a very different
opinion even on
where he stands on sobriety and how to
go about it
uh and then well farrell a very
little-known
uh personal relationship though where
you know uh i think will's moment is so
special and
and heartfelt and you go and you see
demi
has obviously 100 million people
following her
on um following her on instagram she's
got
fans all around you hear from her family
and those closest to her
and then ultimately to go and see the
impact she's also had on some of her
contemporaries it's just
it really to me rounded out the whole um
project the big conclusion at the end
maybe the big reveal at the end
is that demi is not sober is that she is
drinking and
smoking weed in moderation um
how did you feel ending with that are
you worried about how her fans might
take it about how the world will take it
have you talked to demi about
the response to that and what it will be
we did we talked about it and in the
documentary
uh we were very careful to not preach
any uh one-size-fits-all solution and
very careful to say that nobody
struggling with these issues
should follow demi's lead demi is
exploring what works for her very
actively she's still figuring out what
works for her
this is her truth and she's not saying
it's perfect she's saying that she's
figuring it out so uh it was important
to me and to us
and and i felt the responsibility also
to include other opinions of people that
don't feel
like the path she's taking is the right
one and again we're also saying
that the rest is unwritten i mean
there's a very powerful moment when she
says you know you're not going to go and
open up
a tmz article and see me as the headline
in a negative way again
um but i say that with humility and
knowing how
that it's a powerful uh disease so
i think that again you know for me the
goal is to provoke dialogue and to talk
about
uh these issues and to destigmatize it
all because
people go through it everybody's uh got
their own unique struggles and journey
and the best thing to do is seek help if
you're able to
the best thing to do is talk about it
and not just allow to live
in your head and nowhere else so uh i do
anticipate
a conversation to start uh and i hope
that it ultimately helps people quite
frankly
i'm re-birthing i am starting over i'm
engaged
i've really struggled with this are you
entirely sober now
i've had a lot of lives like my cat you
know i'm on my ninth line
i'm ready to get back to doing what i
love which is making music
i'm not living my life for other people
or their headlines or their twitter
comments
[Music]
how do you think she does feel about the
final documentary
i think she feels liberated i think she
feels like she doesn't have to walk
around
with a facade or wondering are people
going to pick up on this or
you know i've said i'm the poster child
for that but i'm not sure if i'm really
doing that anymore
people evolve people grow and you know
there's there's going to be no aha
gotcha moment after this she says
i am a work in progress i understand
what a serious disease addiction is
i understand that i am battling x y and
z i mean you'll see the film but yeah
she ultimately
is saying i am working on things every
single day i've put systems in place
because i am a flawed person
here's where i am today and i'm i'm here
to tell you my journey so
um i think she's really proud of the
work and excited that people will know
demi for demi